[Music]
i'm dahlie bolshandor i come from from
serbia
novi sad i come from inclusive
theatrical
artistic group
per art
[Music]
before i was a performer i was i was in
in some
deep personal crisis
and then
the
the director of uh
of this working sun
center had to suggested me to that i go
to peratt and i thought it was a very
very uh
interesting
how they rehearse
what they refer
and it looked
uh
especially interesting to me because
it was a
it was a a little bit challenging
i described my
my work as a
as something of a contemporary dancer
but
but more uh
a performer
my colleagues are my inspirations
my motivation is my
willingness to do something that is that
is
useful and and also be because i love
what to do i love to to come in in front
of the the audi audience i like to be
known if i could make a performance uh
what should it be called and i said it
it would be called we are not monsters
and then there is question why and i
said because
people are looking at us like like some
kind of monsters in that way then they
don't socialize
with us they are scared of us
i think it is important for disabled
artists
from from other places to
to come to together firstly uh because
uh because they can
they can
exchange their
their experiences or maybe i should we
can change
our experience
we can
learn so much from each other we can
make
new contacts
new friends also
[Music]
[Applause]
what i like to achieve in the in the
future is
to make real difference
in in the world
in a sense that that more and more
people will start to look at us
as different and also
also want to achieve this that we
perform in front of more of audience
and i also want to work with other
choreographers from other places so that
so that i can explore my
my creativity and my
limits
[Music]
you